anyone know any good - jokes
I know you do Vincent I don't like I
know what but it's not the best one but
it like it happen the conference
actually yeah
so so you know at the conference's you
very often have these recruiter booths
right no they are sponsoring you the I
think you say I but it's not always
talking to recruiter it's at some point
of it was recruiter who came up to me
said hey do you use Python - and I said
no I used Python 3 is the king of these
kinds of jokes but Dad now you need to
be the one having the best dad jokes at
this phase you know but I don't think
I've felt up enough like programming
credit to know some good dad slash
programming jokes you know I can tell
the joke the ends of the bike shredded
tweet and you're like haha really plays
well at this Meetup - kids all right I
do
camp and I have a two and a half year
old and a six month old kind of a
handful at the house I'm madelung yes
III think I'm the very British and say
that one could say that if one comes
running in I think I've already
mentioned one time seen the door open
that we're not paying to a see the
entire world so I think I've already got
that dead comment no no my girl is
people a seeing already in Austin oh
yeah okay what is it the heat or is it
also do you mean
think we've lost Jim yep we're also
getting more people maybe let's start
Christian shall we
sorry it's Jim Becky hello everyone very
happy to have you on board today one
hour may meet up as you can see that
image made this first be with you
and before we start mowing so we are in
Hamburg boy we try to adapt it very
important to keep in mind we are
recording this session and we're going
to publish on my data's YouTube channel
so in case you would like to participate
in the Q&A sessions and you wouldn't
like your voice to be on the internet
and so on and so on so just keep that in
mind so it's important also if you don't
want your video or if you don't want
your real name to be out there so we
encourage you either to turn off your
video or change your name and and so on
so it's just that you be mindful on on
that if you have any questions so you
can just go here a little bit down and
raise your your hand this would be
fantastic and then we are going to
unmute you if you can take a moment now
maybe we are going to introduce
ourselves but before that so this is Phi
Beta homework 8 by theta is a global
community for developers and users of
open source data tools
it's a educational program often on
focus and here you can find more
information about the official channels
we are on theater as pi day for homework
so if you want to
share any experiences about the talks
you're going to see today feel free to
do so so a little bit about our hosts
for tonight my name is Camila I work as
an IT consultant at Beiersdorf and also
Christian maybe you'd like to introduce
yourself hi everyone I'm Cristian I'm
work as a data scientist and I do this
freelance and on the side I try to bring
you a pirate a meet-up and how more
every two months together Camilla at
this point very nice so if you would
like to take a moment I mean we are we
are 20 people at this moment we can even
have this option that you can just say
where you from or if you want you can
also write on the on the chat so maybe
if you would like to to just right where
you are from and if you are ready
working with in data science or not so
if your your first time in this pie data
Hamburg Meetup
please feel free to do so one very
important thing it's really about
community at this point so we are really
looking forward to have speakers and if
you are building anything interesting
with open-source data tools speak about
it
we're especially looking for
underrepresented groups and first time
five data speakers and could be that you
tell us yeah okay you know I am working
on something here I'm just not sure if
it's good or not reach out to us we are
always help to take a look and also
support could be also the other option
that you say hey Camila I'm too shy I'm
not able to stand up to do a
presentation so we can always help you
to prepare and just put it in a sequence
in in the best way as possible in I
think it's really about sharing it and
putting out there so we can also support
on that in case you would like to
organize these meetups or help help like
with planning speaker outreach or any
kind of support reach out to us we are
we're also
looking forward to having more
volunteers at this point as we are
talking about the Kobe 9:18 situation we
are not holding the meetups on-site so
we are basically doing everything online
but I hope in this future we also are
going to be back and hopefully you can
have us issue interested in sponsoring
us this would be fantastic so just
taking a look a little bit here on the
shed so we have people joining us from
us now I think it's in Geneva it's been
we also had to hear people from Kaiser
Kaiserslautern a Berlin Hanover also
Berlin from medium but also leaving us
Hamburg we have someone from Hamburg
here boy it's good to know there's
someone from Hamburg here already
concerted I say okay we have the whole
word here but no one from Hamburg as
they had even to people from Hamburg
Bremen as well also another one Sophia
yeah but also living in Hamburg so
welcome everyone so this is our agenda
for for today and we just would like to
announce that we were supposed to have
choice papers today
damn it he had a little problem and he
couldn't join us but we are going to
have being sent and we extended the talk
for one hour so and this is the
suggestion we would give today that we
have two parts and we can decide later
on after the first part if we need a
break or not and how it would be the
best way to do so part 1 part 2 then
networking and closing I would like to
hand over now to Christian and then he
can introduce more about Vincent and
also Jim I would like to hand over to
Jim's joining us today and Jim the stage
is yours to say about few words audience
Jim from our parent organization long
focus and PI data organized in
yeah no thank you I do want to first
thank everyone for joining this is great
so thanks for having me I am my name is
Jim oice I work for gnome focus and
sometimes people wonder like what's kind
of the relationship between them focus
and PI data Numb focus is a non-profit
501c3 company that organization that is
located in the United States and we have
two main kind of missions that we think
about as a nonprofit and one is to
directly house and sponsor about 33
open-source projects some of those
projects include like Jupiter and pandas
and numpy and okay like a lot of
projects that people hopefully use and
love and so we provide certain services
for those projects like financial
administration some legal support we do
other kind of like admin and like Zune
support and we help raise funds and we
do small development grants stuff like
that so we kind of consider that as half
of our mission and then the other half
of the mission is to directly support
the users and developers of those tools
and that's kind of where I come in
I'm an Events Manager for them focus and
one of the main ways that we do support
our global community is through PI data
and PI data is both kind of like a
meetup series where local volunteers and
organizers will host monthly or
bimonthly quarterly meetups and then the
other piece is we do have a conference
series that we run last year we had
conferences in London and Vinson is was
one of the organizers for the Amsterdam
conferences for years now or Lin here in
the US we have ones in like New York and
LA we have one in South America and
India so we do try to keep it global to
be as accessible as possible to everyone
obviously this year we are seeing that
our conferences are not in person very
understandable considering everything
going on but we are lucky that a lot of
our organizing committees are still
trying to find ways to gather people
virtually
and as an example Amsterdam was going to
have a conference in June from 15 to 20
June in person and now they've made it
into like a virtual PI data fest which i
think is a great idea and they're kind
of leading the way on different ways
that we can bring people together
virtually so maybe what I would say is
if you're interested in finding out more
on any of this we do have a website just
for PI data that's PI dated org or you
can go to the gnome focus website at
dumb photo sorg and or please I'm
inviting you to email me directly at Jim
and um focus org if you have any other
questions or just interested in other
ways you can get involved you know
obviously know this is possible without
people attending and contributing so
again I want to thank you for
participating I want to thank our
organizers and please invite you to see
how else you might be interested in get
involved so with that we want to say
thank you and I'll hand it back thank
you so much Jim for the introduction and
now it's my task and my pleasure to
introduce Vincent but I think I need a
bit of help for dad so hey Siri oh
you're doing Siri I feel good Syria have
a question sure just ask Siri do you
think that conversational interface is
the next big thing I don't have an
answer for that is there something else
I can help this sorry I'm having trouble
hearing you
that's okay see we just sit back and
relax and enjoy the talk by Vincent he's
going to tell us about conversational
interfaces I'm quite relaxed very very
relaxed okay
conversational interfaces are coming to
an end
Vincent is very knowledgeable about that
he's doing research and develop advocacy
for the T Madras that had come and he's
asked us to follow along his life
building demo section a bit particularly
me so I hope I can keep up Vincent the
stage is yours cool so I really
appreciate the introduction with like an
artificial intelligence failure that's
always good to point out with these
systems and so what I will do first is
just people can just this way because
then I think people can see the screen
now right people can see this checkbox
from the command line thing yes okay
good so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
make a chatbot and we're just gonna do
that life coding style and what I've got
here is a terminal now this is my
development folder what I'm just gonna
go ahead and do is I'm gonna make a new
directory and the directory is gonna be
called demo demo demo demo or whatever
like I've many demo folders so this will
be the fifth one I've made but I'm just
gonna make a directory in here there you
go
and what I'm just gonna do is start a
new virtual environment in here now I'm
using Python 37 and what you can then do
from Python 3 7 and I believe 3 6 as
well as you can call the vient module
directly and just make a new virtual
environment appear by just using this
part in one line of code this will make
a virtual environment and what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to install razza inside
of that virtual environment the downside
is this razza has a bunch of
dependencies including tensorflow
so installing mice take a while but I
figured it would be a good idea that we
have this thing installing in the
background while I start explaining a
little bit about conversational
interfaces and what's tricky about them
and why an open source solution is
probably a good idea so I'm just gonna
source this virtual environment activate
it and let's do it the neat way with the
module thing
then I'll do Python pip install rasa
this should be the only thing you need
but this install can take a while so
just checking christian kamilla so far
I'm not going too fast I hope I'm
perfect so this stuff is installing and
we'll get back to it in a bit but what I
kind of want to talk about are like
we're gonna build a chat bot from the
command line it'll be the end goal of
this entire little workshop but let's
talk a little bit about chat bolts in
general so my name is Vincent definitely
ask me anything about chat BOTS but what
I am is I'm a research advocate so it's
my job to make sure that whatever
research we do at rasa that people
understand why we're doing that research
and also I do my best to make sure that
I even gel eyes our open source stack so
what I'm gonna do now is I'm just gonna
talk to a chat bot that's supposedly
state-of-the-art so what I've done here
is I've opened up the conve I from
hugging face and hugging face is an
impressive company and they're really
doing some good work but this is a state
of the art chat pod in a sense that it's
doing everything fully generative and
I'm just gonna talk to it and we'll see
where it might fail it's gonna be
different failing than what we saw with
Siri though so we're gonna type hello
here it says hello how are you doing and
let's pretend that I'm interested in
buying a pizza good I want to buy a
pizza and then it says that sounds good
I'm a freelance accountant and the thing
is like if you think about everything I
was doing and the fact that it has to
generate all of this text I mean there's
definitely something state-of-the-art
happening here generating this
grammatically correct sentence is on its
own certainly not unimpressive but if I
now say Pizza hawai please don't let's
start saying that it is a freelance
accountant and that it has OCD which is
an original response but this is not a
system you want to put in production
that that's kind of the thing it's it's
a really cool demo but I really want to
have a chat bot that's kind of
constrained that says hey for this one
use case you're allowed to have
responses
because in this case you know it's
talking about OCD and they're really a
fan of that but there's also a risk that
maybe the chat ball has learned from a
large corpus of Reddit texts and it
starts swearing which is also something
that you don't want to have in
production so even though it is still
definitely like a state of the art
result this is not something that at
some point you're gonna go and put in
production and I'd rather we kind of
care more about you know the theory and
articles are great but we want to have
chatbots that actually go ahead and help
people so that means that we typically
design our assistance with a little bit
of a constraint but one thing I should
point out first and foremost and that's
I'm assuming a lot of you are data
scientists and a lot of you are familiar
with this system called scikit-learn
that's pretty much the the get-go these
days and you know you know scikit-learn
pipeline life is relatively simple we've
got this X that we put into our system
and then at the end we get this
prediction that comes out and we can
have all sorts of like pre-processing
steps in here and machine learning
models in here and that's fine but one
thing goes in and one thing goes out
we're making a chatbot it's a little bit
different because we still have let's
say one thing going in we have a user
here that says I want to have pizza but
then the assistant in this case needs to
detect multiple things for starters we
need to say hey this uh pterence that
indicates a certain intent namely this
user wants to buy something but not only
does that user want to buy something the
thing that it wants to buy is a pizza so
we have to sometimes may be able to find
entities in the text that are relevant
for processing the message and then we
have to give it back an action and this
action sometimes has to be driven by
custom Python code so we are definitely
going to do machine learning and there's
definitely neural networks that are sort
of in the background of this but I do
hope that at the moment already you
recognize that we're really in a
different domain we are not in this
simple pipeline one thing goes in one
thing goes out but what Raza offers is
essentially a system where you can still
put in your own custom pipelines and
components here but Raza also offers the
framework to deal with all of this
around it and to give you a bit of an
example of that this is actually
somewhat involved I've got this one
example of a person trying to order a
pizza here so you know we've we've got
the user here and then we have the
digital assistant over here and a
theoretical conversation could be that
you say hello and then the first action
that this this assistant has to do is it
has to reply with hello back after that
the assistant has to listen we have to
not send anything back but the action
that we should do is we should listen to
the user to figure out what to do next
then the user in this case could say hey
I'd like to buy a pizza and then the
digital assistant says Oh what kind of
pizza would you like and what the user
that might do instead of actually
answering this question the user might
actually throw some sort of an
interruption that says oh yeah by the
way are you a human or are you a digital
assistant and then it will be nice if
the chat bot was able to say well first
I'm gonna answer your question then I'm
going to pick up the conversation where
we left it and then I'm gonna go ahead
and listen again to what the user has to
say and this whole system all the
machine learning you need for this
razza is a nice open source tool to
handle this situation but that's sort of
what we offer but what I hope that you
recognize is that we don't have the same
pipeline anymore and also we're training
the system for a sequence of tasks it's
not just text goes in and a single
action comes out as you see in this
example the sequence of actions that
have happened so far they really matter
so that so I hope you also agree that
we're not gonna start this research by
loading in a CSV file I mean that's not
gonna work for our use case here
need to have some sort of a data format
that's a little bit more than just CSV
so we're gonna start a new browser
project in a moment but there's a couple
of files that
Arase projects should have the data for
this project is typically stored in
markdown files and it might be a little
bit counterintuitive to what you're used
to because it's not really common to do
machine learning or markdown files but
the idea is that markdown gives us sort
of a domain-specific language to declare
conversations and that's typically quite
useful so in this example I have my '''l
unit MD file here and NLU stands for
natural language understanding and the
idea is that we can specify a certain
intent so right now I've got the intent
for a greeting and then under that I
have a list of examples that fit that
specific intent and what's nice is that
this file will eventually get into get
and it will be easy for people to add
examples to certain intense or add an
intent but we basically say here intent
examples intent examples that that's the
way that we're gonna define the
understanding but having just an intent
is typically not enough because we saw
the example before that we have this
order that we have to keep in mind and
you can definitely assume that you know
saying goodbye usually happens after
saying hello and not vice versa
so yes we have this part of the data but
we also have are these stories and the
idea is that if this intent is like a
Lego brick then a story is where you can
click these Lego bricks together to fill
sort of two constructs a conversation
that could have happened in the past so
for example we have this happy path over
here where somebody says hey hello the
robot says back hello
utter greet and then the user says I'm
happy and then the robot says ok I hear
that you're happy
that's a example of a story that's a
conversation that could have happened so
if I can ask greed and greed move rate
of both intents in this case no that's a
really good question by the way mood
Greed's is the intent
utter happy is the action from the
assistant so we have some definition of
an action that should happen over here
and the idea is that the training data
that we're generating to some extent
there's a machine learning model that
will detect a given this intent this is
probably the best action that we're
interested in but there's also a
different model that will sort of handle
the fact that we're moving a long time
here as well I'm not going to go too
much in detail because this is meant as
a more of an introduction thing but
mapping this text to the correct intent
we typically refer to that as a
classifier but given a sequence of
intents and responses what's the next
best action now we call that a policy
and it's a different machine learning
model so to say but for all times of the
question is too detailed but an intent
if it happens later in the story can
trigger a different response technically
yes so you're right there technically
you are completely correct
so one example I have I have one example
of this this is something I made a demo
for today actually it was part of my job
so let's say I have a chat bot that has
a countdown so the user says I want you
to count and then the first response is
ten and then the user says okay and then
the next response should be a nine and
then the user again says okay and the
next response should be an eight right
that's something that could happen but
now if the user were to say are you a
bot then the correct response here would
be to say yes and then a seven and if I
were to ask are you a both here then I
should get yes and then a six so this
context is handled by the policy system
so to say but definitely I hope you also
agree that depending on what happened in
the beginning of the conversation at the
end of the conversation I might need to
give a different answer as well
but the trouser does have mechanisms in
place to deal with this a good question
by the way another thing that's useful
to mention I suppose is we see a nice
example of that here we it might be the
case that we have a certain intent and
then we have to say oh here's two
actions in sequential that have to
follow and that's also an option here it
doesn't just have to be we say one thing
it can also be here's like two actions
in sequential and also after after we've
just done this action we should always
listen until the user says something
back so listening is also an active
action so to say
anyway back to the main topic we have
these intents and we see that these
intents are used as stories but that
means that we have one last Lego brick
to deal with and that is what about
these actions we have to define those as
well and typically those are stored in
this domain but yamo file and that's
just a configuration file where you can
say hey here's all of my intents and
you're also able to say and here's all
these actions and responses typically a
lot of these responses can be simple for
example just say a little bit of text if
you're making a frequently asked
questions chatbot then usually just
sending some text back can be fine
but we are also able to add actions in
here that are just Python code so then
you can customize whatever response you
would like an action could be some
Python code that fetches some
information from a database etc but we
have to declare our intents and our
responses and also some entities in this
domain at yema file that's what that
config file is for
there's one final configuration file and
that is aptly named config gamal and the
idea behind that file is that that is
where you define your machine learning
pipeline now we have a ml file here
because we think that's convenient but
in the back all the code that you see
here is just Python that's running you
know some tensorflow code and in the
case of this count vectorizer thats i
could learn but you can also add your
own custom Python code in here if you
want to experiment with your own methods
that's completely possible but these are
typically 2 4 files that you have to
specify in order to get a chatbot
running and I hope that given the
examples that I've shown you that it's
plausible that we need more than there's
a CSV file we need these settings files
in order to get started a benefit of
this is that we don't necessarily have
to write a whole bunch of custom Python
code to get started because these four
files on their own will be able to cover
a lot of ground for us so just a
reminder we have 4 files at our disposal
that we have to use the configured llamó
file machine learning stuff domain the
demo that's the overview of all the
intents and the responses and custom
actions the stories are examples of LEGO
bricks click together that represents
conversations that could have happened
in the past and the data that Nou file
that has all sorts of examples of
intents and entities that are meant to
sort of give training data towards a
intent
you
so just to quickly check
Christiaan any questions on this
anything unclear I was wondering if you
um intent detection is a classification
problem you teach by example in that
case you need to provide enough examples
to detect this particular intent is that
right
so you're completely right there the
question is I it is hard for me to know
when I've given you enough data and in
general at least in practice I can make
this argument let's say that this is all
the data that we train on and it means
that those are all the examples we've
given to our system and let's say that
these are all the conversations that
users actually end up having with our
chat BOTS and there's the the main
problem I think in production is that
you usually come up with paths and
stories that you think users are gonna
have then when you put it into
production you realize actual users
actually behave a little bit differently
but you are completely correct in the
sense that it helps if you have this
panel you file that you definitely
supply with more examples note though
that we do have word embeddings at our
disposal as well and the way the way to
improve is providing samples there's
nothing about syntax or keywords or you
just well I mean there's also this
notion of conversational design right so
you as a programmer get to decide when
am I gonna use entities when our intents
enough and how our user supposed to
interact so I don't want to discount the
fact that conversational design
definitely matters here but in general
you are certainly correct the more valid
examples that you have of training data
the better the only thing and we'll see
that in a moment is that it is a good
idea to come up with training data that
covers a lot of ground I can come up
with 10 examples which are all
variations of spelling for the word
hello but it would also be good to say
greetings and happen you know come up
with a little bit of ground covering and
data set so to say so the ideal case
would be your examples are everything
that could be said in this everything
every way that this could be formulated
in terms of machine learning training
performance I would argue yes but it's
not going to happen in real
and also I mean we should also be aware
that the more data we give this thing
training times are going to increase and
we will get a limit there at some point
as well and we can use GPUs with raus I
mean all that stuff works but in
practice my advice is to give this to
users as quickly as possible because in
my experience so far no chatbot goes as
planned in the sense that you cannot
predict what people give to these chat
BOTS some pure gibberish in practice how
long do these files need to be how many
examples do you need until you see some
good results what what might be better
in that sense is how about we just make
a chat bot right now we'll just start
locally and my goal will be to fool the
chat BOTS we're gonna see if we can
break it and we'll find out it's
relatively easy but but it will but one
thing I have to warn you for it is a bit
of a cat-and-mouse game and that's
mainly because I don't know exactly how
my users are gonna end up using my app
and if the distribution of stuff I get
in production is different than what I
have in training and you're gonna be in
a tough spot and I would argue that
that's probably the main concern before
you movie there is a question yep
here in the chat how does any human
human of conversations as reinforcement
modify any config or domain or override
it this is a question that's in the chat
as well so can i where's that button
it's normally on your thought oh wait I
think so I'm using two screens here and
then I think I can click more and then
chat and okay well that's fun it's grand
how does actual human human conversation
has been forcefully modify any configure
the man so we don't actually the idea is
because we have this idea of
we do constrain the algorithm a little
bit because we can say these are all the
intents that you're able to detect and
also these are the only responses you're
able to give back so we're not really
using actual human to human
conversations here now there are systems
that do that and the hugging face system
that I showed you earlier something in
that realm but for now I think the state
yard is not in the position where I
would comfortably put something like
that in production the main reason being
if your corpus has swear words in it or
chatbots kind of swearing and typically
when you put something in production you
may constrain the artificial stupidity
more than you want immediately optimize
all the artificial intelligence you've
learned from Microsoft a that that is a
industry reference yes there's another
example which I thought was interesting
you can google the photo it's pretty
funny so I think this was a photo taker
and from the earliest chat BOTS at
PayPal and then a chat bot says hey I'm
still learning but you can ask me
anything and I'll try to help you and
then the person replies by saying oh I
got scammed and then the Bob reply great
which you know is some ideal response
but that totally there's a photo of that
mmm but again let's very quickly just go
into this demo because I think it's
gonna give a couple of nice examples too
so we've just done rasa installed rasa
and one nice thing is that that gives us
the rasa command line app now this one
I'm sorry
currently and we're trying to fix this
if you try to get like the help from
rasa here it's gonna be a little slow
because there's all sorts of tensorflow
libraries that have to run in the
backend of it
so instead of doing the help of showing
you everything command line can do how
about I just run the init command and
what this command is gonna do is it's
gonna initialize the project so that
means that we're just gonna get a clean
starter kit to play with now again this
is gonna be a little bit slow as still
tension flow has to be imported and
loaded and all that stuff but I think in
a couple of seconds we should see
something
Proms that says oh you want to start a
project select the folder to be
interested in yep there we go let's make
this just a little bit bit here depends
on what like I think most people should
see at least something like this
just checking people are noting but I
think it's fine so you have to give her
the path where the project will be
created and I think the current
directory is fine because again I'm
doing this in the demo demo demo folder
it's asking it's not empty is it fine I
think it is so I'll just say yes and the
next thing that it's asking me is if I
want to train an initial model and I do
so what's happened now is a bunch of
files appeared and we're now also going
to say use those files to train an
actual chat bot it's gonna be super
basic but we're just gonna go ahead and
train this and what you should see now
if she shoots if you used to care us you
should see some things that you might be
familiar with like this epoch thing you
might have seen that before if you're
using Karis but essentially here you're
seeing that we're training a bunch of
systems ok so some more stuff is
training
does a GPU come in handy so I the thing
is probably it's just like enough I've
never really needed the GPU myself and I
will say that that's a benefit but like
my I have colleagues in the research
team who do use their GPU the thing is
that we are currently trying to figure
out what's the best way to benchmark all
of this because there are parts it was
because there's bottlenecks etc it's a
bit of a detail but do you there are
speed ups that you can achieve using GPU
most of the stuff that we're using is
based off of transformers so we're not
using LS CMS as much anymore in our
stack so that seems that the
improvements that you should be able to
get are should be reasonable anyway you
should now see something like this where
hey yeah we've trained an assistant on
the command line so we could go ahead
and sort of start talking to it so I'm
gonna start talking to it and everyone's
allowed to sort of do the same thing
I'll zoom in just a little bit okay so
this is the demo of a very very basic
chat bot but what I am able to do now is
I'm able to say hello this it's asking
me hey how are you I can say I am sad
and then it's telling me that there's
something to cheer me up so let's let's
put that mysterious link in a browser
and see what happens wow that's a cute
picture of a cat so that's it's always
nice did that help you I can say no and
then the chat pod says goodbye again I'm
what's I'm not suggesting that is the
best assistant ever but this is the
basic demo now yeah so I think we have a
little bit we have enough time for that
so this is the basic thing you just got
running so what I'm just gonna go ahead
and do now is I'm gonna ctrl C out of
this and I'm gonna just open this folder
up in visual coach studio and there's
this nifty little shorthand command that
you can type called code which will open
up the app but you can also just point
to the folder and I'm just gonna work
from here for now because from Visual
Studio code I also have this terminal of
my disposal now you can just source the
virtual environment here and then this
will be a good place for me to
demo some stuff I suppose so what are we
gonna go ahead and do is I'm gonna go to
this data folder and I'm gonna open the
NLU 2 MB file and you should recognize a
few things like we have this intent
greet which is detecting the greeting
for example and we also have this intent
goodbye as well as a firm of an eye a
mood great and the mood unhappy these
are all in here and there's also an
intent for challenging whether or not
you are a boss which is a really good
intent to actually implement but but
these are sort of the intense and I hope
we recognize that from the slides I
showed you earlier we then also see that
there are some stories and again we see
that there's the greeting which again is
the fine over here and then we have a
greeting we have a response we have the
mood great we have the response and
there's a couple of paths here now
there's also this domain a demo file
let's just quickly have a look at that
and we see a list of all the intents but
the main thing at least to us is we also
see these responses so utter greets for
example that's actually listed in here
and there's the utter cheer up where we
get some text as well as an image and so
I hope we recognize some of the separate
parts that we've talked about earlier
and what we can also see here is that we
have this config dot yellow file and
again these are all these settings for
the machine learning stuff that we're
running we're not gonna really change
this as much but I figured it'd be good
to point out that these are here and you
can also point to your own custom Python
classes from here that's also totally
possible what I'm not gonna go ahead and
do is I am just gonna go ahead and type
rasa shell what rasa shelled am I going
too fast by the way just to check
just a little okay that's all I'll slow
down a little bit but what we're gonna
do now and I think after this we'll just
have a like timewise would it be good to
have a break now or just checking we
started at like 6:30 I think right
I know what do you think I think maybe
we can ask the audience guys the ones
that are would you like to have a break
now maybe five ten minutes before the
break also there is also one question in
the chat so maybe maybe we can guys it
was a sign please I'll keep going for
like five more minutes and then we'll
have a quick break and then I'll answer
any questions that people might have
that might be a good balance mm-hmm
cuz cuz we have these files but now I
want to show you hey let's see the robot
fail and then we'll see if he can fix it
so in particular what I would like to do
now is i'll type r as a shell and razza
shell is just gonna give us the
interface that we had before so nothing
new per se takes a while let's get
started but once it's there yes so I can
type hello here and we get the hey how
are you and I can also type hide and I
can also say yo and I'm gonna I would
argue that this is a very clear failure
all right so I type yo and it thinks
that I have to say goodbye and the
question kind of is well why is that
well for starters yo is not listed here
as one of the possible intents so there
you kind of go it's probably this count
factor that hasn't recognized and also
what we're doing here is we are so far
only using if you look at the config
file
the only real features that we're using
here are count vectors so we're not
using word embeddings or anything like
that
yo probably would have been picked up
correctly if we're using word embeddings
but we're not just what a good question
at this point yeah does it always output
an intent or is there a kind of a
default or failure mode if it doesn't
clearly detect there are settings that
you can tweak for this and all um so
there's two ways of dealing with this we
give you the option of saying hey well
first of all let's have an intense four
out of scope
that's one thing that we can do and it's
actually not the worst idea so suppose
you have a chatbot for pizzas if someone
starts talking about fire hydrants that
would be an excellent opportunity to say
hey let's fall back so you're gonna have
to fall back in 10th that's one thing
that you can do the other thing that you
can do is we have this idea like all
these models they have some sort of
probability that they output some
confidence level it always sums up to
one and we have this fallback policy
where we can say if the difference
between the top two classes if the
difference between that probability is
really slim okay we need to fall back
and ask the user to sort of repeats
themselves because that way we might get
a sentence that's easier to detect so
then I was wondering where the buy comes
from when you type inyou like does it
automatically go to the most probable
class or does it go to the goodbye
intent so let's have a look at that
because what I can do is I can also type
rasa shell and all you and that's gonna
give us a little bit more insight and
what the model output is and we're just
we're just gonna investigate this for
now because I I agree with your
curiosity now one thing about this mlu
is that this is going to completely
forgo the order in which the
conversation happens these are just the
classifiers for the intents and the
entities that we're going to be looking
at but for debugging purposes we are
going to get more information so let's
start by saying hello again and now we
get this big Jason thing that we can
stare into and what you can see here is
that yeah definitely greet that's that's
the most the highest one but now let's
say yo didn't just see what happens yeah
so it's definitely confused here and if
I if I were able to hypothesize what is
going wrong here we are using count
vectorizer x' and we're looking at
character engrams as well and if I think
of the word yo right this is a Y in
there and then always well so I can
imagine it eventually probabilistically
that's the reason why we see
so what's the most probable class yeah
oh yeah that's that's certainly true and
but one thing that would be nice now
though isn't and that's something you
know if you see this in production you
would label this and what we can do now
is we can just add the word yo here and
the nice thing about this is this gives
us an opportunity to call rouser train
once again and and at this point you
know this is a really minor change but
one thing that I do think is kind of
nice about this syntax is note Howard
sort of looking at this file as if it's
a config file and if you think about
machine learning pipelines I do think
there's something elegant about your
data actually being a config file as
something that you actively maintain as
such so in that sense it's it might be
uncommon to write your data in this
format but I hope that we also recognize
that Mary love it now one thing that
just happens because we just retrained a
new model if you pop open this models
folder you will notice that there's a
new file here with a date/time stamp in
the name and that's because we just
trained the new model and every time you
call rasa she'll well we are doing
internally is just grabbing the most
recent one but you can also select a
flag that says open up another one but
note that this thar over here you can
upload this and set that into production
this is just everything that we've
trained and zipped but now if we go to
the router shell and we do the whole yo
thing again then we should see an
improvement
okay so I'll do yo now and it's now
being detected correctly and again this
is a little bit cheating of course
because the example is literally in the
training data at this point in time but
I hope that people recognize like oh
yeah we just trained a new model the new
model appeared in this models folder and
that's picked up by Raza failure so what
I'm hoping is that at this phase people
recognize that if they want to add an
intent or more examples that they have a
feeling on how to do that I mean sure we
haven't shown you two steps yet but if
you want to add examples you just add
another row here in this Nou dot M V
file if you want to add an intense we
can just copy this and give it a new
name here and fill in these examples
well we don't have to do is we have to
add a story here and then we have to
make sure it's in this domain at Gemmell
and what I could do now is I could do it
a demo where I take all of those steps
and I show them to you but I think that
you know that these are not the hardest
things to do and I imagine and at least
I imagine that we're a little bit more
interested in seeing how entities work
and how we can get our custom Python
code running as well
so what I would propose we do now is
just half the little break like a couple
of minutes and then what I'll do is I'll
share a git repository with you that
contains a pokeymon chat bot that I am
building that is meant as an open source
example but that has a custom Python
component in it and it also has examples
of enemies that we can go ahead and play
with as well very good do we need to
know anything about to follow or just
barely if for all intents and purposes
we all agree it's some Japanese kids
show that's five years like I'm not the
biggest Pokemon expert I get corrected
all the time on Twitter like all the
time
but first I just want to make sure that
the people's questions are answered at
this phase I think this is a nice little
milestone in that sense so give me all
your questions and if you want to grab a
glass of water go ahead
and someone says pika pika and that's
okay okay and pokemons go that's good to
know so there was a question by prom
night is there a way to programmatically
populate in tents there yes
so definitely then there's even packages
that do this I I I do want to mention
that you might want to be just a little
bit careful there so the idea is that
you might be able to say well it's for
the one I'm gonna come up with all sorts
of questions about Pokemon so you can
imagine I have what pokemon has this
type and then the type is something I
can loop over maybe I can replace the
word wats with which and I can generate
all sorts of training examples there the
analogy here is that this is reasonably
similar to deep learning and images
where I take an image of someone's face
and you rotate that the idea behind it
is okay but if it's one person's image
and just rotating it 10,000 times we
shouldn't think that that's ten thousand
data points um and with that in mind it
might actually be a better idea to just
sit down with a bunch of people and
actually grab a thesaurus to make sure
you're covering a lot of ground instead
of just repeating the same data over and
over again that's a risk that we have
seen at clients one thing that's
interesting about this particular
problem is that one of our researchers
actively working on this we are trying
to figure out if we can come up with
generative algorithms where you give us
five sentences and we'll generate 20
that are similar you can select 3 did
you like those are now all in the
generative parts and then we generate
more of them and we think that that
might actually be a pretty valid use
case for generative algorithms because
we're using that to generate training
data that you yourself still label this
is an active research project but if
people are interested we do have collab
notebooks where people can try this out
themselves as you might have noticed
we're a pretty open company when it
comes to research
many more questions in a chair please
Camila this is there was just one
question now when talking about entities
is it mandatory to be taxed or it can be
numbers for example I create story that
asked how many tickets and user answers
in integral three instead words how has
a solve this problem it's from rally
yeah now so we have tools for that so a
couple of ways we have this
I think it's called duckling if I'm not
mistaking so we have this duckling
entity extractor and duckling is just
there's a bunch of heuristics in there
and they're really good for getting like
numbers and monetary amounts and then
that sort of thing so if you want to
fetch all the dollars out that's why I'm
way of doing it and you can also select
entities by giving us a red X that's
also something that we can use that it's
X enemies and recently this is a feature
that we released I think three weeks ago
maybe two we are now also making roles
and groups for entities so you can say
hey this is the first dollar amount in
this utterance and this is the second
dollar amount that I've seen the idea
here being if suppose you're making a
chapel for an airline then you have two
cities but one of them is a destination
and the other one is where your is the
origin so the entities that we train for
can also have that context attached as
well this is a new feature
I should add to that but definitely if
you're more interested in just getting
numbers out we have some you have some
components that are specialized towards
doing just that
if there are no more questions what I
think I might do real quick is I'm
noticing that I have a bit of a dry
mouth now from all the talking and that
can be really annoying to listen to so
I'm just gonna run downstairs to grab a
quick glass of water and we'll I'll be
back in like 30 seconds okay so maybe we
can do five minutes break
you
you
also by the way yeah hi Little Wolf
okay so there's some people asking
questions and I'll just answer them here
so there's one question so hi again
little but they someone asking a
question which models doesn't as I use
in its back end it's some kind of Bert
model or sequence models at the moment
our preference seems to go out to
transformer architectures so the
transformer seems to work really well in
the dialog use case at least that's what
we've seen so far now what you can do is
you can use Bert's
as a pre-processing step so the word
embedding that comes out of the english
bert model for example it's something
that we can totally pick up and eat so
to say now on the topic of LS CMS in GRU
we have noticed at least in our
benchmark so far the Transformers just
outperform them a little bit not
necessarily in that we double the
accuracy or something like that but the
results are just a little bit more
stable you can use custom Spacey models
in Raza as well we consider them
pre-processing tools but Spacey in
particular can also be used to detect
entities as well and I'm just gonna i
wrote a guide on how to do that and I'll
just post that in in there there we go
blog Raza custom components there we go
so Spacey is definitely a source for
word embeddings that you can use inside
of Raza
that's definitely the case one thing I
do want to add there is Spacey's
definitely a great
but spacey is meant as a general natural
language tool so to say so that's
general natural language problems
chatbots are a bit more of a niche in
that domain we have found that they are
definitely still useful so we love
supporting it but the but but but there
but it's not to say that Spacey models
will always work out the best typically
you still have to do a little bit of
customization on your own end
so things that I was wondering something
similar is there any kind of
pre-processing happening for the
examples in the intense definitions so I
can where I'll show you I could show you
a little bit and all it can I share the
screen that might make it a little bit
easier so if you go to this configured
yellow file over here right you'll
notice that there are some feature
risers so to say and feature risers
could be word embeddings they can be
dense vectors they can be sparse
features etc and so far everything that
we've listed here they are sparse
features these are features that in
general they mean is the word
capitalized just know which word is it
and which character Engram do we have
but what I could do here is at a spacey
model that's something that I could do
and then I can say something like what
language do you want to have you want to
pick German or what-have-you and that's
the setting that we can put in here and
that's because the spacing model is
something that we support now you can
write your own custom Python codes to
get your own word embeddings in here I'm
currently writing a small library such
that we also support fast text that's
not going into Kaurava but this is
something I'm gonna host on github but
those and just like Bert but those are
dense feature Iser those give us dense
features and that's gonna go into
whatever classifier you're interested in
here now the way you should look at this
pipeline though and that's just a side
comment is this pipeline is
significantly different then
scikit-learn because as I could learn
you have your X and then that's passed
through a pre-processing step and then
you have
new EX that sort of comes out inside of
rasa what's happening is you have your
old ex and then you pass that through a
component block and then you have both X
as well as the new thing it's a
dictionary where we just keep adding
features to that that's our data
structure so that means that this diet
classifier can just look at whatever
features it likes to ingest and I'm
gonna take just the the editing of this
pipeline like what what kind of
pre-processing what kind of models is
that something that chatbot developer is
expected to do or is that the
perspective the raza engineers
optimizing so what you're getting at is
grid search I think like that that's
eventually where you're gonna end up and
there are two sides of that I think for
one there are these different choices
where you can make a principled decision
without having to need to look at the
the grid search per se so for example if
you're well-versed in transformers then
you might be able to say okay this is a
complex task I need this many layers of
transformers for example this bit here
this is a count vectorizer that does
character level count vectors so that's
sparse representation but if I take the
word hello oops my bad so if I look at
the word hello then I can have a chi e l
ll and l o right and I can have counts
for them having this is amazing if you
have a chatbot scenario where people
make spelling errors because then that
feature can really really compensate for
that so there's a little bit of domain
knowledge when it comes to features for
certain models that will help you but we
definitely still run grid search but we
do that from the command line
my question was a bit more high-level
like in the process of creating a new
chat but this editing of the pipelines
is something you do you need to
experiment
to achieve that's true but but it's but
the thing is at the same time you should
also be worried about your data set
right so there's always a bit of a
balance what we do if you go to
our documentation page we try to
generate just a couple of reasonable
starting points to try out so I think we
have like about three examples where we
say okay if it's super heavy weights try
this if it's in the middle this is a
good starting point if you're using
English use that so we have a couple of
these starting points that we give you
to go ahead and try out first and that's
typically your starting point so
building a specific bot is still a data
scientists job even though
razza makes it very simple and provided
some good tools for that yeah so most of
the users that I'm aware that I'm aware
of then again my might be biased I don't
know every browser user but we have
found it to be somewhat less common that
people make that people write their own
components now I think a part of that is
because our documentation on how to make
the best custom component yourself now
there's some stuff missing there so
that's something I'm working on this
month but so far we found that as a data
scientist and also sort of the team
who's building a chatbot usually the
first roadblock you hit is how do we get
this a to production and B how do we get
data in the loop and how do we label and
how do we get that thing rolling and
only then you're at step three where how
you pick the best pipeline is really
going to be something that you can
actually gain a lot of value from missed
it again so far how do we get it to
perform well in terms of intent
detection you need to experiment yes I
should say on all the algorithms that we
make ourselves we have a youtube channel
that explain how these algorithms work
and especially this diet classifier the
third video I've made for that also
shows you how you make certain choices
when it comes to actually designing a
chatbot so the we tried to make you know
this content that says hey we're trying
to design this chat bot here's some of
the choices we made and why so I would
write if you're interested in that I
would recommend our youtube channel
so I think we're I just want to check if
there's any other questions though let's
dude that's real quirk okay that's a
really good question a YouTube channel
named algorithm white board but Pete
eyebrows on YouTube you should be able
to find it um so question the like here
is which tokenizer is used by
transformers well just like I can set
the different features here I'm also
able to select a different tokenizer so
definitely if using hugging face you're
probably not going to be using the white
space tokenizer but the bird feature
users that we have there from hugging
face and we also implemented the hugging
face tokenizer so what you didn't have
to do is if you're using a bird feature
from hugging face here you will need to
use the tokenizer from hugging face as
well but that won't we keep everything
consistent so I think that's most of the
questions answered so far so I'm gonna
assume can I assume most people are back
now reasonable I think I think they are
good to go good so what I'm gonna do is
go to github and I think github slash
rasa HQ is what you're gonna want to
have and then CR opens two projects here
but there's like rasa rasa del Rosso SDK
there's a bunch of them what you cannot
type in here though is pokedex
and I think if you type in
okay Dex - demo rouser into Google you
should also get here but just to
reiterate get up calm slash Raza HQ and
then there is this pokedex demo that you
can find and what I'm just gonna go
ahead and do is I'm gonna clone this a
cheesy HTTP but for my co-pilot you
probably want this with SSH instead
because it will be nice you can make a
merge request in a bit and what I'm just
gonna go ahead and do what's used just
to do cut for that go back here I'm just
gonna go ahead and do is I'm just gonna
do a quick and dirty thing I was gonna
make you're gonna clone rectly in this
folder here and it might be better to
move that to a separate repo that's
that's definitely valid but I'm just
gonna make the Pokedex demo pair in the
folder I felt over here and any reason
for is I then have access to the virtual
environments but you can definitely put
this in a purse or fuller as well nice
and what I'm gonna go ahead and do gonna
open the Pokedex demo in a new window
for visual studio code not save anything
they've done here
and what you should see is some it looks
really similar to the rasa init program
it's just that here we have different
examples in our Enel you to MD file and
there's also this pokemon DB the JSON
file over here but this is in all
intents and purposes still more similar
to Raza and NIT than than anything else
but one of the things that you're going
to notice here is that there's a couple
of different intents in particular
there's one here called demand joke so
one of the features that I've made is
I've made this intent where the user
says that they want to learn hey they
want to hear a Pokemon based joke so
that's an intent that I have added and
you'll notice that I've actually come up
with a bunch of ways to ask for a joke
here another thing that I've done below
here is I've got this intent but there's
also some entities here so for example I
could have an intense where I'm asking
the chat BOTS could you confirm if this
pokemons name exists that's technically
exactly what the Pokedex is supposed to
do so you can say hey is Bulbasaur a
Pokemon and in this case with this
syntax we're saying bill bazaar this
string that is an entity of type Pokemon
name but the name of the Pokemon so to
say and in this particular case because
there's lots and lots of these Pokemon
I'm probably not gonna have an example
for each and every single one of them so
we have these utilities like a lookup
table so in this particular case I can
say hey here's all the pokemon names and
then Raza is able to figure out all
right so then I can replace whatever
pokemons name is listed in here and I
can put it there generate some data and
that way I don't have to come up with a
example of every single Pokemon that I
have and and the reason why I like
showing this is Raza has a couple of
these utilities so to say they kind of
make it easier for you to declare a
whole bunch of these entities so you can
also come up with things like synonyms
so you can say NYC instead of New York
City and that's also something that you
can declare this DLS dsl star the same
to occur it still needs to train with
all of these generated examples it's
just a way of automating the creation of
training data like yeah it's it's it's
just so that you as a developer have
less cognitive load on this yes and also
the way that we generate these training
examples is we look at this story
then we say oh we had a greeting here
okay we're gonna grab a greeting okay
this one and then we're had a we had an
action and then we're gonna take another
example of this and that's how this
training data is generated on your
behalf but we automate that such that
you don't really have to bother with
that that much but you can see here that
definitely I have some more intense and
I even have an entity here at the bottom
so that that's that's something that
that's relatively exciting so let's have
a so we've had a look at this an alert
and B file so the next thing that you
might want to have a peek at are these
stories but the stories files not
particularly interesting the main thing
that is interesting is that we are using
our new demand joke over here and we're
saying hey let's alter a joke and then
we say over here that we have a confirm
exists intent that is followed by an
action check existence and one thing
that is interesting is that action here
it starts with the word action instead
of the word utter so it isn't a
different type of action in that sense
it has a different name and there's a
reason for it if you want to discover
the reason why part of that can be found
in this domain that yellow file you know
we've all of our actions and again we
see that one action sort of stands out
let's check existence one we also see
that the intents are definitely in here
we see that the entities is also listed
here so we've got this entity that the
main files now also aware of but then if
we look at the responses greeting
cheering-up we have a lots of jokes and
our disposal here but the one thing
that's not in here is this action check
existence that's the one thing that we
don't have and that is because this is a
custom action we need custom Python code
to be able to handle that and that also
means that we cannot just have some text
that we utter we actually have to write
that down in a file somewhere and if you
were now to you know check that later
but if you were now to go to actions
that PI you will see a Python file
that has a class implemented and this
this class is called action check
existence and it inherits from the
action class that comes from the Raza
software development kit and in
particular this class has a method
called name and the name of this action
is action check existence so this is how
you make the link to the domain file
that this is indeed a custom Python code
that's supposed to run and there's one
method in particular that where all the
logic essentially gets handled and it's
we might get into the details of this at
the end but the main thing that's
important is that we can happy we can
and we have access to this tracker and
this tracker has all every everything
that happened in the conversation so far
and in particular it has this one object
called latest message which is a
dictionary that has all sorts of
information and in particular it can
grab the entities out for us and what I
can then do is I can say if that entity
type is pokemons name what I can then do
is I can check hey have I seen that name
before
in this pokemons the txt file if I have
well then I can say yes it's a Pokemon
and if I haven't and I can say I don't
recognize the name and in this case I'm
just reading it in from a file but in
practice you can imagine you would read
in from a database here so it's quite
straightforward code right it doesn't
check and offers a message so I
definitely had a world yeah do you do
complex stuff in these actions like
update some states so the thing is you
could and one and there's one use case
for example so and suppose I have the
pizza-delivery chat bot thing so we have
this notion of entities right those are
sort of things that we can detect but
maybe some of these entities are
long-lived like your address for example
isn't that's I don't want to get that
from the last message that's something
that's
to be long-lived so you can imagine that
if currently I don't have your address
yet I might first check the database if
I have it and if I have it there then I
can fill in this thing called a slot and
the slot in Raza is like an entity but
it's long lived so the so that could be
a use case so to say but the goal of
this is in this custom code so that
means that you have the freedom to do
whatever you think you might need want
to scrape a website you can so what you
don't do is write your own state machine
maintain everything but you use the
tools that rather provides like I mean
there's custom Python code so if you
want to go ahead and do that I'm not
going to be able to stop you but I will
gently urge you that there is a better
way of going so so state machines I get
where the idea came from right but it's
eventually it's harder to maintain
that's sort of the idea behind this and
the nice thing about these stories is
that you know you can strain the chap
out a nice way you can actually say oh
this is a story that I assume happens
and yeah I guess you can see some things
like a state machine in here but I have
found it to be an unusual reference
there is a lot of literature on it
though so I get the reference but it's I
have found it it gets in the way
mentally the better way to think about
is hey a user has this intent now given
this intent what's the next best action
that's a good yeah it's it's kind of a
UI thing I would argue almost for
developers but but really good question
well I hope people recognize from this
though unless there's other questions
something about the clarity of grammar
and it feels a little bit off-topic so
I'll ignore that one for now but what I
think might be interesting for us to do
is let's just run this custom action
with a chat bot so far I think it might
be a cool thing to do so
well quickly do now is all we'll need to
start up two things actually
so I'll get the terminal here and what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna start another
terminal on the side as well so I've got
these two terminals at my disposal now I
will source the virtual environment
first and foremost oops
source then oh wait those in the folder
right this is kind of annoying because
the virtual environment is in the folder
in the parent folder I've got I've got
my virtual environments here so that's
good and what I'm gonna do first is just
call Raza train from here because I need
that model but there's a second thing
that I need to do as well and that has
to do with how Raza works so you can
imagine that I have my natural language
understanding part of Raza right so
that's but something of Raza offers and
then text goes in and then we we try to
give you the right action to follow but
then if we have our own custom actions
right the question then is in production
do we want to have those actions inside
of this NLU or should we maybe consider
that as a separate service now if I'm
gonna run this in the docker container
should these two live in the same
container and in production we found out
that just there's a lot of engineering
reasons why you want to separate the two
so that means that you have typically
this NLU service running that will
handle the you know the state of the
user as well as what's the current
action etc but then if a custom action
needs to be called then we have this
action service that we have to call and
that has benefits because we can look at
these logs separately and kind of in the
micro service style of thinking we do
want to have a separate box for this guy
and that means that if I want to now you
know play with these actions I should
run my own action server to keep all of
that stuff simple though what you can
just go ahead and do is you can type
browser run action
and it will just pick up this actions
file and start a server locally for you
if you want to do this more formally we
could package it up as a docker
container and open up the right port but
for now this will just be easier so what
I'm gonna do is in this terminal I'm
gonna run browser run actions and that's
gonna start a servers a service and I'm
going to type browser shell in this one
and that's going to give us the old
shell that we're used to and it should
be able to pick up though that we have
an action server running there's a
config file that I've set in this
project for that this takes a while to
start up
but the bots should now be loaded what
I'll do is I'll just grab this and all
you file so we have this example here
and what I should be able to do now is I
could say hey just hi how are you say
give me a joke
why'd it squirrel across the road
to get to the other tide well not the
good another super good joke but okay
the feature works but now what I can do
is I can say is though thus our Pokemon
that's a question I can ask and we see
that something over here happened and
it's saying here yes Bulbasaur is a
Pokemon so we can see that we have the
natural language understanding saying
hey a certain action needs to be
triggered that message is passed to the
action service and then we get a
response back here and we see that we're
also printing some extra information
here and the extra information that
we're printing here by the way and
that's information you have access to is
all the confidences for all these
different intents they're passed with
the message that you get into the action
server as well so this is a lot to
suddenly see but I hope that we from a
you know if we take a step back the main
thing that's just happened is we have
this custom action over here that is
able to trigger Python code that's
basically what's happened and we give
this message back by accessing this
dispatcher and we're saying hey just
send text back we can also send images I
mean that's also something that we can
send this way we depending on what
platform we are launching this on and we
can also send buttons and then all sorts
of forms etc but we do have custom
Python code handling some logic for us
and I can do something like is boo Babar
a Pokemon and it's still not perfect
because in this case it's unfortunately
detected that we want to have a joke
right so we still need to add examples
this this Chapel is not perfect but I
think if I have the example is nine
tails
right then we trigger the action server
again because this is misspelled racial
again the command that we need to run
the actions yes
sorry if I'm sorry I went too fast razza
run actions and that command will assume
that your custom Python code is in an
actions the PI file so that that's the
one assumption that that thing makes but
this should start the action server
locally so those that are interested
there is this extra yellow file that I
have not really discussed but it's
called endpoints that yeah Mille and you
can specify hey the action endpoint that
I have for this that's over here so
that's because and that's how it's able
to find the action server it's basically
something that you can configure I'm
currently running some experiments to
see if we can also run the action server
in a cloud function that's something
that you could potentially also do here
but in production this would basically
point to a docker container somewhere
it's definitely not perfect but but I do
hope that we see like how the separate
parts work together any quick questions
on this
also from the chat maybe
guys are you still with us okay I just
yeah we have some yes yeah yes we have
some years on the church listen maybe
you can explain to me what's happening
so I typed in the only thing I know the
answer is because she loved Pokemon and
the answer was I do not recognize
Pikachu are you sure this spelled
correctly I'm not sure
Pikachu is spelled with a k did you
spelled this one yeah this is how you
spelled it or you spell it differently
it's about okay so you type is Pikachu
of Pokemon like this with a question
mark and like Pokemon and Pikachu
yeah so I think it's a capitalization of
Pikachu because it's really good but if
the action function that's doing a bit
of a mess up I think one way to fix that
I think is if I look at the entity yeah
so I should call dog blower there I
think that's the the fix or maybe put it
into pre-processing could your car what
do you mean by that exactly I mean if
you want to ignore capitalization in
general could you define it somewhere
the pre process is everything in this
case I would argue all users are able to
capitalize stuff to you right so that's
something that you should be a little
bit mindful of technically what you can
definitely do is write your own
tokenizer that makes everything
lowercase actually come to think of it I
think that's actually a setting of the
white cat white space tokenizer I think
you're able to say hey I want you all
the tokens to be lowercase I would maybe
not do that because you do lose
information that way but you can if you
want to okay I think this is still a
pretty good practice though
we've got some questions in the chat
mm-hmm is Rosa a Pokemon why did I not
trigger
so let's there's a wall so there's a
couple of things happening here in the
background so what I'm going to do now
is I'm going to hypothesize what is
happening here but it's theirs because
there's multiple parts I cannot suggest
that I'm a hundred percent accurate here
so it's saying here I absolutely love
Pokemon so then the question is what
action was triggered and if I go to my
domain that llamo file I think this is a
joke in fact I'm sure it's a joke it's
listed here and the reason why it's a
joke is because absol is a Pokemon this
this joke in particular was a PR from
New Zealand I can I remember that so the
thing that happened here was other joke
was sort of mentioned here so then the
question is ok how can that be well I'm
using the word Pokemon here and I can
imagine that the word Pokemon also
appears if I go to the NLU file over
here so the word Pokemon does make a
couple of appearances in this intent
over here and you know I have three
examples over here with Demand joke and
I only have one example here so that
already is kind of a thing that can go
wrong especially if you further consider
that it's not just the word that I'm
detecting it's not just a count vector
for that word it's also for all the
little combinations of characters inside
of it as well but I'm also generating
lots and lots and lots of features so my
guess is is that that is where something
is going wrong and the easiest way to
fix that is just make sure that I've got
more examples over here this feels like
a data problem I would say
now one thing I suppose it is
interesting I what I can do here is I
can say is rasa Pokemon named a Pokemon
name that exists now I can I have this
example and in this particular case what
is interesting is that rasa does not
exist as a pokemons name but in the
context of this sentence I might be able
to argue that this token over here needs
to be picked up and checked by our
action as if it is a pokemons name so in
that sense I still want this to be
detected as the entity even though it
doesn't exist as an actual Pokemon name
that's also something for this
particular use case I suppose to
consider incredible hypothesis thank you
so at this point in time there's a
couple of things that I think might be
interesting or fun to do so one thing
that we could that the one thing that is
valid I think at this point is let's add
some data and it can be like a nice PR
that's something that we can do but if
we're gonna add more data I think I want
to show you a good habit you got a
definitely we can add like yo here right
I mean that's something that we could -
but when I think about rasa and ways
that me and the research team can help
some of you folks sure we make
algorithms but some of the things that
we're also now open sourcing are
datasets and I just want to highlight
that because I do think it's probably
the most valid way to get started so if
you go to rasa HQ and I think if you do
like NL you yes so if you if you in
github type NL you in the repository
search you will find this NL you -
training data repository and the idea
behind this repository is is that we
want to crowdsource some datasets such
that you have an easier time coming up
with good models so we have some common
things that people in banking like to
use we have some custom scripts that
will remove entities and that's
something you're worried about but in
our particular case we also have this
small talk
file and I'll just open up the raw file
and we just have a couple of examples
listed here that you can just go ahead
and copy and paste and this is something
that's also a community project this is
something that we're actively building
but we do think and we seriously think
that having a good data set to start
with is probably your primary concern in
the beginning you know we can have very
fancy transformer architectures etc but
if the data set is not representative of
something that users are actually going
to type then you know you're gonna be in
a bad spot by your way so if you're
gonna get started with the chatbots
remember that we have these repositories
with datasets you can copy and paste
from so that's the first sort of hint
and tippet I might want to give you and
there's actually a second hint I think I
should be giving as well and to do that
what I will need to do is share this
browser tab because so far I think I've
given like the hello world like I've
shown you the features of razza etc but
I haven't really talked about yet is how
do you actually do this stuff in
practice because you know there's this
deployment story but there's also this
data quality issue that I think is at
the center of all of this and for that I
just want to show you this other
products that we've made called rasa X
and the idea behind Ross X it's free so
you can go ahead and download it and use
it but it's not open source because we
don't want Amazon to host this on behalf
of themselves we are more than happy
that you host this for your chatbot but
we're less happy if you're gonna host
this product and charge other people
money for it but if you're using your
own chat pod you can go ahead and stalls
on the VM and what this essentially is
is a user interface on top of all the
files that I have shown you and we have
you know some sentence that was spoken
and then we can say hey is this the per
crew I predicted correctly and I can say
yes or no and this is sort of a labeling
tool that we can use for that there's a
nice little train button here so I can
retrain all of this stuff and in
particular the coolest feature and I
think that's also something I would like
to remind everyone
this is why you want to install Reza X
is I have this button over here that
allows me to share this chat box with
other people so I can say something like
demo people please play around and this
will then generate a link for me and I
apologize it's an HTTP link not HTTP but
this allows me to give to you a link to
a chat bot made with rasa everyone in
the meeting and you should be able to
interact with that so if I go to this
other browser window here assuming
nothing is going wrong because I am
using a experimental version right so I
should be able to type hello in here and
then we have a very very bare-bones chat
bot yep and the main thing that this
chat bot does is it asks you the user
what features you would like to see in
this chat bot and the reason why I think
that's an interesting way of talking
about it is because I don't know what
pokemons people like like literally no
idea I played the game when I was 10 but
what people can now do is they can say
well I want to learn the Team Rocket
theme song or something like that and
then it says ok is there anything else I
can say yes
simulations will also be kind of nice
you know and then I get a couple of
these responses but the nice thing is is
that while that's happening yep here's
the conversation I just had so this
allows me to do some user tests to
actually get this out there and have
people interact and play with it and the
nice thing about this razza x instance
is that everything that i label there's
a nice little git link so I can click a
button that will update the get surfer
on github and and I also can train from
here and we like to think that this is
sort of from a user interface and
maintainability perspective probably
something that you want to get started
with after you've actually done
everything on your laptop if you want to
get anywhere near production there's
first thing she's probably install so
that's the whole demo that I had in mind
at least so I hope people sort of look
at browser X and go all right if I want
to do something in production this rasa
X is something I should keep in mind
because I do think this labeling and
keeping the data quality high that's
super important but until then I hope
that I have given people a nice
introduction on what we think are good
building blocks for making
conversational
instances and then sort of apps what
what I think is nice about this approach
is that we have this nice little middle
road between high tech algorithms but
still some constraints such that the
algorithm doesn't derail into something
that we don't want it to so that is
something that I think is going to be
really valuable if you want to do this
stuff actually in production and then I
people interested definitely go to the
get up thing and add like some some
intents maybe or like maybe some extra
examples it should be relatively easy
for you to do so but I think watching
other people merge that p.r might be a
little bit boring so probably now is a
good time to do questions instead thank
you so much I have a question right away
speaking about building blocks yes we've
seen it's a bit of a process to get the
right behavior into your chat BOTS you
need to do a bit of engineering but
hopefully everyone will now use Raza and
start building better and better models
and there will be a model that's pretty
good as a small talk and chit chat and
if I want that behavior plus some other
behavior plus some custom behavior that
I built is there an easy way to like
combine behaviors abilities from chat
pods so in an extreme case you could say
oh we have one action server and that
decides whether or not like extreme
scenario let's say you have multi
language
we're German in English let's say those
are the two things we need to have for
this banking app you could take this
super extreme route and say oh you know
what I'm going to have one action server
that's going to determine from there
which of these two rouser instances
you're going to talk to and that's
something that we can build out that way
like the the the thing here is is
because it's all Python we part of that
responsibility lies with you like you
have to seriously think how am I gonna
maintain this the main thing that we try
to do is come up with stable building
blocks such that a lot of use cases are
properly covered so I'm just gonna keep
on with the multi-language use case but
I think it's interesting to most people
so one of the things that we allow is we
allow you to use multi-language will t
lingual word embeddings like bur to have
a couple of multi-language versions of
that but but there is whole notion
conversational design but I do want to
admit is still an unsolved problem this
is all relatively new stuff that we are
trying our best to learn it quickly as
possible and come up to like good
practices but I have to be honest here
like we also learn a lot from our
clients like they have datasets that we
don't have access to so the lessons that
they learn we know we have to get it in
and then in that sense we're still
learning as we're going along we'd like
to think we've got a couple of good
habits but for example multi-language
chat bolts that definitely still work
progress we're not done there and we are
not yet at the point where I can say
okay give me this small talk ability and
then give me the Pokemon and the whole
thing I just plug into the other into
and it's still my job to integrate
everything to some extent we we like the
thing that that's where the datasets
will help you because again we the
models that we make are this finds to be
really general and it gets pretty
state-of-the-art results and that's we
think that for small talk datasets are
probably going to be more effective than
anything else just like to thank you
again
if we're lucky it's a matter of merging
the datasets and then you have these to
be pretty much well so you still need to
map that to actions and intense and
whatnot but really example FAQ but
that's a relatively standard thing
because it's it's pretty much in action
tense action there's no other sequence
of actions that you have to follow
strictly
so we have a couple of these demo while
said you can't go ahead and just put a
copy and then just your own data set and
for chit chat in particular you have a
little bit of data set you can also just
go ahead and copy but I do fundamentally
think that a large chunk of making
general that bots is just having the
mineral data sets yeah definitely a goal
in our science to have like a
standardized data set for chit chat and
German and Dutch pitch in whatever and
then by giving you the data said you
should already cover the ground a bit
there at least one question that they
want to take them directly from the chat
why should I read them to you I think I
think I could take this one could you
show a bit more about rasa X how would
you take a demo conversation I used for
training so super quick demo and I
should I should mention here that is not
the most recent version a more recent
version of Raja X also has like a
keyboard shortcuts that I can't demo
right now but probably ought to go to
hell your training tell us where is
Pikachu and if that's that someone said
that as a the things that will suggest
feature intent and I want to learn a
cat's and indeed simulations and I want
to learn a team rocket's theme song
these are some of my responses but I
think other people saw mentioned that
and the models is hey that's a suggest
feature and I can say yeah that's that
correct I know someone here says please
tell me a joke and the chat BOTS thought
it was goodbye I'm gonna say nope that's
bad and I can say that should have been
a joke yeah mark is correct now okay so
you do this you you labeled a couple of
things and every time you do this
there's gonna be a new line appear in
that Enel you end the file that's
something that's happening under the
hood well while you're doing this and if
I were then to click this button a new
model gets trained and then I have this
models tab where I can select which of
the models is active so that's something
you can all do from here essentially all
the commands that we've
from the command line we have also made
a user interface for that with the idea
that you know it we can extend this
where maybe you have multiple people
that can do labeling and maybe we can
say things like only when two people
agree do we actually put the label on
disk and you know these are features
that we are considering putting in this
and we think that having a tool like
this is going to make it easier for you
to maintain and update and keep your
model in the loop so to say definitely a
lot of work in progress if you get the
newest version you should get the
keyboard shortcuts but that's the flow
typically that you would get another way
of saying this is some of you might have
heard this tool called prodigy the the
Spacey people are the explosion AI there
they have this tool where you can also
do some labeling and this is in a way
like prodigy but we like the thing that
this is specialized towards the digital
assistant chat BOTS use case but that's
why we see this going that for chat
bosses is something that's going to be
super specialized and to that
any other question from the chat
great then why agree as well while
spreading precip I love it it cool so
guys I think it now it's time to make
the question so our initial plans for
today was that we would do a little bit
of networking so we would go for
breakout rooms we would like to get this
question back to the audience would you
like to join us for like 10 minutes
networking we can split the people
between two or three what do you think
give us a thumbs up if you would like to
go into breakout rooms later on my end I
kind of went over a time that I thought
I was going to be and my girlfriend is
getting a little bit impatient in terms
of cooking downstairs and so I won't be
able to stick for too long I hope people
don't mind there is sorry there is just
one question last question we get here
from the chat what is definition of your
company for how you can work on open
source yeah not a cool question so Rosso
rasa is fully open sourced so everything
that we've done terminal and stuff
that's super open source there is an
enterprise version of rasa X that people
can pay for and we also offer support
and usually they have people who go for
the enterprise license for rasa X you
know there's like LDAP and some of those
integration features they also go for a
support contract and that currently
finances and that's sort of the way that
we intend to make money at the moment
this factor mentioned we are vc-backed
so we have a little bit of a buffer so
to say to do the marketing and sort of
become the elasticsearch of chat box
that's sort of a third way of thinking
about it but there's an enterprise model
in ROS X that's the that's the revenue
idea
okay seeing people saying thanks people
didn't say if they want to go to the
breakout rooms or not so is it now so no
response okay so the I think I'm not the
only person who's making someone wait
for food very good guys I hope everyone
learned something here it's been my
pleasure to present and he wants to say
big thanks then to Vincent for the
presentation and we see you all again
back in July and very important if you
wanna give a talk get in touch you have
here our also link heading group by data
Hamburg groups or just give us a message
a shout out on Twitter and we are really
looking forward to hearing from all of
you again stay healthy thank you so much
thank you so much for joining us and see
you in July ciao ciao
you